[Music]
you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up
a new tool to map plastic waste from
space can it help government solve the
pollution problem
an energy company boss calls for the
government to step in before rocketing
prices see millions fall into fuel
poverty
and are music lovers more likely to
commit to climate action than the rest
of us
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world hear from
the people being hit hardest by those
changes and reports on the race for
solutions so new satellite technology
has allowed scientists to map plastic
waste from space for the first time
global plastic watch can detect plastic
sites as small as five by five meters in
near real time and much of this waste
ends up in the ocean so just how bad is
plastic pollution well it's estimated
that 8 million tons of plastic enters
our oceans every year that's on top of
150 million tons of plastic that are
already circulating our marine
environments and as a consequence
plastic has been found in more than
sixty percent of sea birds and in
hundred percent of sea turtles who often
mistake plastics for food so
could tracking plastic pollution using
this new satellite imagery tool freely
available to the public to help solve
the problem either bennett reports
it is a blight on our planet that is
only getting worse the equivalent of one
truckload of plastic waste enters the
world's oceans every minute but now for
the first time our plastic pollution can
be mapped from space in what's being
seen as a potentially game-changing
breakthrough plastic pollution may
result in
in health issues both uh to ecosystem as
well to human that we don't quite
understand yet um and so i think it's
exceptionally important that we tackle
uh this growing issue
global plastic watch uses satellite
imagery and artificial intelligence to
map plastic pollution on land in near
real time it can detect sites as small
as five by five meters 26 countries have
been mapped so far with the aim of
preventing plastic from flowing into the
oceans
each of these yellow dots represents a
plastic dumping site and if you click on
one
you can see what it looks like from
space now because it uses satellite
imagery that's updated fairly regularly
you can track how the size of the site
has changed over time that's the yellow
pattern here
and if you click on street view
then you can see what it looks like
on the ground
but how can they be sure the rubbish on
land ends up in the sea in some cases so
uh uh it is very apparent from the high
resolution satellite imagery so you can
almost just see it like waste gets piled
up and then a monsoon comes by and it
strips out all the waste from behind
the free technology is already being
used by indonesia the fifth highest
contributor to ocean plastics but
developers say it's not about naming and
shaming rather empowering governments to
stem the tide iva bennett sky news
well on the eve of the queen's speech
the head of one of the country's biggest
energy suppliers has called for the
government to be more proactive in
easing costs for consumers the head of
scottish power says 10 million
households should have their energy
bills reduced by a thousand pounds to
avoid falling into energy poverty but
the government says they'll do nothing
more before the autumn helen ann smith
is our business correspondent
it's a pretty stark intervention we've
seen from the ceo of scottish power he
is calling on the government to do much
more to help people with the rising
costs of energy bills he wants a
thousand pounds taken off people's bills
that he says can be paid for over 10
years either by putting small amounts on
people's bills going forward or through
taxation he essentially makes the point
that energy bills are already some of
the highest they've ever been the energy
price cap went up to 2000 pounds a year
in april that is set to go up again
because remember that price cap was set
before the invasion of ukraine which has
sent wholesale gas prices soaring even
higher than what they were so it's
expected that come october that price
cap could rise to as much as 2 500
pounds a year maybe even up to 3 000.
and his point uh keith anderson's point
was that that's just going to be simply
unaffordable for people we're a big
company and we can survive and we can
get through this okay but what we're
saying is with the rises we're seeing
and the price going to that level we
can't do this on our own so i can't help
customer customers on my own deal with
this price and deal with in effect for
over a period of 18 months would be a
200 increase in their energy bill that
requires the government the regulator
and the industry all to work together to
help sort this out now the timing of
this intervention is very salient it is
just after the local elections where the
conservative government has taken a real
hammering in the polls and the key issue
it took a hammering over was the cost of
living but also it's the day before the
queen's speech and we are expecting an
announcement on the uk's energy strategy
the long-term solution to this
is more energy security whereby we are
in control of our own energy prices we
are not beholden to russian gas and the
wholesale gas price uh that even though
we don't buy a lot of russian gas we are
beholden to the price
across the market
so more
news tomorrow probably on nuclear and
renewable strategy things that the
government will hope means that things
like this won't happen in the future
well let's have a look at some of the
day's other climate news now because
plans for a uk-based mineral processing
plant that will supply enough lithium
for one million electric vehicles have
taken a step forward green lithium a
company that plans to build europe's
first lithium refinery in the uk has
struck a deal with commodities trading
giant trafagura at the facility in the
north of england will provide lithium to
gigafactories from 2024 as countries
increase their production of electric
vehicles in the quest for net zero
new measures to protect forest elephants
are being introduced in gabon where
playing a key role in conserving
rainforests now officials are set to
introduce eco-tourism sustainable
forestry and electric fences to keep
them critically endangered elephants
away from crops and humans the
government there says it's achieved near
zero deforestation and plans to increase
its protected areas from 20 22 to 30 by
2030.
the duke of sussex has taken well a
starring role in a video promoting a new
eco travel campaign travellers now the
non-profits organization has introduced
a rating tool on the website for new
zealand where holidaymakers rather than
holidays are rated for how sustainable
they are in the video prince harry is
confronted by kiwi actors playing the
role of
rating agents who rate him for his
environmental performance during his
2018 royal tour of new zealand
you scored three stars three stars out
of what 100 100 no out of five okay okay
funny uh so yeah not too bad according
to my notes here you were given 12
towels at tim's motor lodge and you only
used one for the entire stay so pretty
good i don't think i stayed there and 12
towels that's pretty excessive i mean 12
towels is excessive oh you were very
respectful of local communities in fact
you even bought some local honey yes i
remember that was that nice
uh
yes
now we're getting quite personal now but
bear with me if you listen to music say
in the shower or on your way to work or
maybe you've booked tickets for that
festival you just can't miss then you're
more likely to be more committed to
climate action than anyone else that's
what we're hearing today from a new
study called turn up the volume and
it also suggests music lovers believe
tackling climate change should be a
priority above other issues well lead
author of that study is dr matt brennan
associate professor of popular music at
the university of glasgow and he joins
me now matt thanks so much for joining
us and i suppose my first question is
that music culture has a
long history doesn't it playing a key
role in in pushing so social movements
this must be encouraging data for you
yeah i think that there's maybe a myth
actually that music was maybe more
linked to social movements in the 60s
and 70s but in recent decades maybe lost
some of that wider social resonance but
these findings really show us that the
link between music audiences and broader
social consciousness is still very
strong when it comes to concern about
climate change in particular
and matt you spoke to it's up to about 2
000 people
who are these music lovers that are
closely aligned with climate change what
did you learn from them
yeah we spoke to just over 2000 adults
across the uk and importantly they
weren't all music lovers the survey was
distributed by yougov to a broad range
of respondents and that's what allowed
us to make a comparison between fans and
non-fans so we asked people to rate how
important music was to them personally
and also in their daily routines and
from that we got a data set of about a
thousand fans for whom music was
important or very important and roughly
a thousand others who said music wasn't
so important to them and we could then
compare those two groups when it came to
their attitudes and behaviors on climate
change
one of the takeouts matt that i found
quite surprising is that 82 of music
fans say they're concerned about climate
change um but 54 of music lovers believe
tackling climate change should be top
priority above other issues um what do
you think the findings what do you think
you can do with those findings rather
and how can that be used to tackle
climate change in real terms
yeah i think we can use them in at least
two ways first we can use the findings
to persuade the music industry to take
even bolder steps towards reducing their
footprints ones that might even require
audiences to change their behavior a bit
because we now have data showing that
music audiences would support that more
strongly compared to the general public
and then second i think there's an
opportunity to engage music audiences
who feel more strongly about climate
change to help drive change maybe beyond
the music industry because music may not
have a very big carbon footprint
relative to other sectors of industry
but it does rely on that much bigger and
quite unglamorous infrastructure of high
emitting industries like transport
manufacturing construction and so on so
we can think about new ways maybe that
we might encourage music fans to adopt
sustainable behaviors as a way of
accelerating green transition across
that wider infrastructure and society
that they're already embedded in
thanks matt well do stay with us coming
up
i'll be joined by sally iran from forum
for the future and chaitanya kumar who's
head of environment at the new economics
foundation will be discussing politics
and culture have we reached a tipping
point in the climate conversation
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm david blevins and i'm skye's senior
ireland correspondent
[Music]
i'm based in belfast a city transformed
by peace but still struggling with its
past
politically the two sides are as far
apart as ever and it's over that
question of who has sovereignty in
northern ireland
the very issue that's been the source of
tension here for
generations it takes 60 minutes to cross
the irish sea it took the british
monarchy a century
i've spent 25 years reporting the
journey from conflict to peace
the political parties of northern
ireland have reached agreement
we help you understand the world with us
today
we have reached an agreement with the
conservative party on support for
government
in parliament
we already know what the government gets
out of this deal what exactly does the
dup get out of it well 1.5 billion
pounds
welcome to winterfell it's an iconic
location in this globally acclaimed
drama
ophelia was the most powerful hurricane
this far east in the atlantic on record
you can't live in a place like this and
not appreciate the environment
the plan is to take the political
temperature midweek so we'll be
discussing the biggest stories of the
week so far talking about what's still
to come having a look at prime
minister's questions of course and
getting reaction from politicians plus
our very own viewers and we'll have
analysis from my sky news colleagues the
take with sophie ridge on sky news
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news well let's get
into some of those climate issues now
with our guests uh sally uran from the
forum for future and chaitanya kumar
thanks both for joining us today um i
just want to
start off with our first big topic
because um you would have heard last
week local elections the green party
made record gains didn't they uh they
now have over 540
council seats across the country and in
particular the party made history in
coventry as it took its first seat on
the council 50 years after the political
group was formed in the city so sally
let me start with you first of all
could you tell me why you think the
success of uh the greens has sort of
turned into this big story at the local
elections
yeah i think there are a number of
reasons i think the first is that we are
just hearing more about sustainability
and climate issues in mainstream media
and we're seeing more of climate change
issues as we go about making our
shopping choices when we're in the
supermarket when we're online so i think
this agenda has started to come into the
mainstream and this is coupled with the
fact that we're also seeing changes in
our climate the massive heat wave
reported in india last year last week
but also closer to home and this also
comes at a time when actually the green
party were quite specific about what you
could do as individuals in terms of
insulating your home reducing your
energy bill so in the face of a cost of
living right right there were some very
specific
guidelines there which i think probably
resonated with people at a time when we
really are struggling with cost of
living and i can see that you're nodding
your head chaitana are you in agreement
then about the success of the green
party being down to those key issues
like the cost of living
yeah i think so i think
some people on the political right
certainly wanted to see this as a almost
like competition between cost of living
and acting on climate change if you want
to solve one crisis you have to sort of
ignore the other but i think this
election was a further vindication of
the fact that we don't have to look at
them separate issues they are
interlinked and stacking climate change
and tackling that zero can have
implications for dealing with cost of
living and vice versa as well
i suppose climate action
um is something that lots of people are
thinking about and with the green party
in particular
you would take from this that it's not a
fringe party anymore people are not
protest voting they're not going to the
lib dems or going to labor they're
picking the green party as their main
political preference this time round of
course local elections are quite
different as sally mentioned earlier
point about insulating homes for example
we argue that when it comes to
insulating homes retrofitting homes
local authorities have a very important
role and therefore having green
councillors
leading your wards i think is a very
good sign but of course there's a slight
difference between national elections
and local elections as well it'll be
interesting to see how many candidates
at the national level perhaps get into
parliament in a couple of years time but
i think the it's a good sign that
climate change is very much of the
agenda and i wouldn't be surprised if
it's one of the top three issues leading
up to the elections in a couple of years
i'm glad you brought that up chaitanya
because sally i was going to ask you
what you think this says for the future
and a general election for the green
party
i think this is great news i think this
is an indication we might be at a
tipping point where the public
consciousness about this agenda is
really hitting how people are making
their political choices and choices
about how they live their lives and so i
agree i think we're going to see an
increasing spotlight shining on this
issue and it will be up there in the
political discourse because this affects
everybody and i think really why the
greens did so well is that often climate
can feel quite disempowering it can feel
quite hard to know how to navigate this
really complex agenda but simple
messages about what you can do at home
how you can build local communities
these are all things that we can action
and i think as we kind of bridge that
divide between the theory and reality of
how do we respond to climate then i
think we'll see this elevating up the
political discourse
well it feels like doesn't it sally that
climate action is in all stages of life
in particular in the media industry
because um did you guys watch the baftas
last night at all
i had to confess i did watch some of it
yes you did great because there was that
big moment wasn't there in terms of
climate action when the duke of
cambridge he praised television writers
for including environmental messages in
their shows to keep climate change in
the minds of viewers so uh prince
william if you didn't see it said
writers and producers are playing a
unique role in ensuring the future of
our planet is something that we all want
to talk about so sally he highlighted
the uh the bbc's big spelling bee that
was a really big one for him i'm sure
he'd very much welcome this show um he
also spoke about uh the north london
derby on sky sports where there was a
sustainability quiz between two top
football players and i think 2.6
million people watch that game in
particular
this relationship between the media
industry and environmental issues when
did you notice a turning point
i think probably in the last 12 to 18
months as we headed into cop26 for the
first time in my career i saw a really
serious conversation about the need to
have a mainstream discussion around
climate and i do think the media has an
incredibly important role to play if we
look about how big change happens and
certainly our response to climate needs
to be bridged within this big change
then behavior change narrative shift is
so important and changing the narrative
from a set of issues that people don't
necessarily understand or care about
actually this affects us all and this
something that we can all do is so
important so i was delighted to hear
that intervention last night and it's
really really timely we have seen more
broadcasters bring in these issues into
their mainstream broadcasting sky is a
great example
but one stat looked at scripts over the
last five years
of mainstream tv productions and less
than three percent talked about climate
and this is impacting us all and so i'd
love to see more from media because
shifting the narrative of this is an
agenda that will impact us all and we've
all got a role to play the future isn't
written
so chaitanya we were talking about
prince william there but prince harry
was also involved in pushing the climate
agenda
with his involvement in that video to
i guess rate holidaymakers rather than
holidays and give tips on you know
eating locally how important is it that
members of the royal family or big
celebrities get involved in trying to
push the agenda for climate change
yeah i think it's quite important i i
enjoyed the ad uh i giggled a bit it was
funny um but i think the celebrities
have a lot of pulling power you know
they have millions of people following
them on social media
every word they say obviously can
potentially become news and then talking
about climate change is obviously quite
important quite significant i suppose
the difference of course is there's a
risk that we may end up having
celebrities just talking about recycling
or like turn the lights off and things
like which are all important to mind you
but we need a lot more than that we need
governance acting and i think
celebrities can push the boundaries of
what
they can do politically as well and
perhaps you know let their followership
and and and fans
also perhaps be more politically active
and the other story that we were talking
about earlier on was about music and how
music lovers are more likely to be in
tune with climate issues um sally i
wonder are you a music fan do you think
this is true
i do um because music speaks to how we
express ourselves our creativity
and for all too often the conversation
around climate has been quite a
technical conversation
it's popped people off because it seems
quite hard to understand and the science
is really scary however if we can unlock
a creative discussion about how we can
work together so celebrities civil
society business government then
actually we reshift the narrative into
something that we all can grab hold of
and play a role in delivering
okay thank you sally and chaitanya thank
you so much for joining us today on
tomorrow's show i will be joined by
economist vicky price and climate
columnist at the independent donna chad
mccarthy well thanks for watching
everyone and we'll see you next time bye
[Music]
you